do you
remember the taste of the last
orange you ate do you remember
the warmth of that welcoming cup of tea
that you had when you came in from the
cold
november rain do you remember
the smell of the hair
of the first love that you kissed but
i'd like you to try and hold on to these
sensations because
i'm going to come back to them welcome
back to the machine learning street talk
youtube channel and podcast with me your
host
dr tim scarf if you want to be exposed
to completely new ideas
and challenged intellectually then this
episode is probably the episode for you
last time we had a philosopher on the
show we had absolutely atrocious viewing
numbers
but i'm a big believer that we need to
be challenging our preconceptions
on absolutely everything pedro domingo
said that there were only five
tribes in artificial intelligence and he
didn't even consider
the other tribe which not many people
talk about
cybernetics cybernetics is the science
of communications
and automatic control systems in both
machines
and living things we're going to discuss
ai across three key dimensions
today computability understanding
and the phenomenological experience or
consciousness
when we talk about artificial
intelligence what we basically mean
is the science and engineering we're
trying to
engineer machines to do things that we
might say is clever
professor mark bishop does not think
that computers can be
conscious or have phenomenological
states of consciousness
unless we're willing to accept pan
psychism which is the idea that
mentality is fundamental
and ubiquitous in the natural world or
put simply that your goldfish and
everything else for that matter
has a mind pan psychism postulates
that distinctions between intelligences
are largely arbitrary
mark's argument is distinct from cell's
argument that computers cannot
understand
and also from roger penrose's view that
some tasks which humans perform
are simply non-computable he thinks
that there is no objective fact of the
matter about which computations
a physical system is computing
this is because of the observer relative
problem which mark will
outline in great detail in today's
episode many of the ideas we're going to
discuss today are anathema
to the current modus operandi in
artificial intelligence research
just the reading list we got from mark
today will keep us busy
for the next year mark's work in the
philosophy of ai
led to an influential critique of
computational approaches to artificial
intelligence
through a thorough examination of john
cells
the chinese room argument and we'll be
discussing that in great detail later
mark is also the scientific advisor to
fact 360
a startup deploying artificial
intelligence using natural language
processing
for e-discovery or detecting malicious
insiders by
subtle changes in language in human
communication networks
insiders who might pose a threat to your
organization
and they use sophisticated graph
analysis to do that
mark just published a paper called
artificial intelligence
is stupid and causal reasoning won't fix
it
he makes it clear in this paper that in
his opinion
computers will never be able to compute
everything
understand anything or feel anything
for much of the 20th century the
dominant cognitive paradigm
identified the mind with the brain
you your joys and your sorrows
your memories and your ambitions your
sense of personal identity
and free will are in fact
no more than the behavior of a vast
assembly
of nerve cells and their associated
molecules
you're nothing but a pack of neurons
and that was according to crick in 1994
the church turing hypothesis stated that
every function which would naturally be
regarded as computable
could be computed by the universal
turing machine
if only computers could adequately model
the brain
then the theory goes it ought to be
possible to program them to act like
minds with its myriad of features
running the gamut
from causal learning reasoning and
understanding
even bengio observed in 2019 that we
know from prior experience
which features are the salient features
and that comes from a deep understanding
of the structure of our world the church
chewing hypothesis has triggered an
explosion of interest
in biologically plausible neural
networks
we had dr simon stringer on the show
last week talking about
the spiking dynamics the temporal
binding circuits which
emerge when you create some of these
biologically inspired neural networks
but
i'm not just talking about the
biologically inspired versions even the
relatively pedestrian vanilla neural
networks that we all know and love on
this channel
this has all been um a huge focus point
for the last 50 years or so
ai eschatologists like ray kurzweil and
nick bostrom
believe that there might be an
intelligence explosion where
all of humankind will inevitably be
crushed
like ants although viewers of this
channel will well know
francois chaulae's response to this view
alan turing deployed an effective method
to play chess in 1948
many decades ago but since then we've
seen
little progress in getting machines to
actually
genuinely understand to seamlessly apply
knowledge from one domain
into another judea pearl
believes that we won't succeed in
realizing strong ai
until we can equip systems with a
mastery of causation
he thinks we need to move away from
simplistic probabilistic associations
to machines which can reason causally
he even proposed a so-called ladder of
causation
which is seeing doing and
imagining which i feel is almost
self-explanatory actually
unfortunately for pearl deep mind have
already demonstrated several times a
reinforcement learning system
which can perform causal reasoning and
counter factual analysis
and it seems obvious to me because if
you're interacting with a system
then of course you can learn the causal
factors i'd completely take pearl's
point that
with traditional machine learning where
you're not interacting with a system
you can't learn any causal factors that
seems quite intuitive
anyway all of this is small fry compared
to the point which professor bishop
wants to make the idea that these
silicon ensconced algorithms can become
thinking machines becomes a little bit
bizarre
once you realize that a machine has no
choice in what it does
computation is not an objective fact of
the world
it's observer relative even wittenstein
said that the meaning of a computation
is in its use he thought that
understanding could not be a process
and therefore it cannot be a process of
symbol
manipulation whether a given individual
understands
is often external to that individual
mark's intuition is that evolution
autonomy and environmental
interactions give rise to
phenomenological consciousness
he thinks that we cannot live inside a
computer simulation
because he can feel the sensation of
cool air on his face
so mark thinks that the meaning of
computation
becomes relative and lies in its use by
humans
mark gives several examples in the show
this evening demonstrating precisely why
he thinks this
so i think mark's main contribution is
this dancing with pixi's reductio ad
absurdum
he quotes hillary putnam in 1988 the
influential
american philosopher hillary putnam
published a paper in which she showed
that under the influence of
gravitational waves and cosmic rays
the subatomic particles that make up all
the objects of our world
your seat the seat you're sitting on the
very clothes you're wearing
the room that we're in they're all
containing a rich dance of subatomic
particles a dance that never repeats
itself
and putnam realized that this is
analogous
to a state machine going through an
infinite series of non-repeating states
so it then seems to me that if a
computer
a terminator perhaps is conscious purely
as a result
of moving through series of
computational state transitions
then if i know the input to that machine
with input fixed
i can generate exactly the same series
of state transitions
with any large counter like a car's
milometer
or following hillary putnam's move with
any open physical system
so if a machine is conscious merely as a
result of following some computation
then consciousness is everywhere
in the bricks of this building the
clothes that you're wearing the very
seat you're sitting on
they are all experiencing the zing of
that orange
the warmth of that cup of tea and the
memory of your first love's kiss
if machine consciousness is possible
everything
even the smallest grain of sand is
filled
with an infinitude of conscious
experiences
bishop interprets putnam's result to
mean that computationalism demands
that every physical system is host to a
multitude
of conscious minds which he refers to
as little pixies since a
computationalist believes
that to be a conscious mind is just to
implement the right kind of computation
not only would we be surrounded by
pixies
but the vast majority of conscious
experience would be
realized in these pixies
since any physical system is
implementing any
and all computations simultaneously
then all possible conscious minds must
be instantiated simultaneously
in every physical object for bishop
this is the most patently absurd
manifestation
of pan-psychism and thus demonstrates
that computationalism
must be false so it seems like a
contrarian position that bishop is
saying that
computation is very much in the eye of
the beholder
whereas most of us think that
computation goes on inside our brains
anyway the key takeaway from the dancing
with pixi's reductio ad absurdum
is that computation doesn't have those
phenomenological conscious states
a finite state automata cannot give rise
to conscious experience
unless conscious experience is in
everything
bishop says that he's an embodied entity
which is to say
he's not just thinking in his brain he
thinks with his body
and his body in the world
in today's episode we also talk about
some of the greats of computability
mathematics and logic starting with alan
turing on computability
he described a machine called a discrete
state machine
i now call it turing's discrete state
machine because that was the first time
i read about it in his work
so over any short time period we can
replicate the behavior the different
state transitions of turing's discrete
state machine
with any other one such as a digital
marometer but because when we added
input
the number of possible state sequences
grew exponentially
we can't easily do the same thing when
you have a machine with input
but then i realized if i know the input
to one of these machines
that combinatorial state structure
collapses again just to a simple list of
state transitions
he invented this interesting thought
experiment called the discrete state
machine
and he had this physicalist desire to
explain all of humanity
via a computer program and interesting
what he learned later on in his career
about the non-computability of numbers
led to a significant amount of tension
for him later on in life and his
children the american philosopher john
cell
was so exasperated that anyone might
seriously entertain the idea
that computational systems purely based
on
the execution of appropriate software no
matter how complex
might actually understand
it was it was ridiculous he formulated
the now
infamous chinese room experiments and
we'll go into this in some detail in the
show but essentially he said that
syntax is not sufficient for semantics
and that programs are not
formal and minds have content therefore
programs are not mines and
computationalism must be false now
most of the chinese room argument is the
first
proposition which is that syntax is not
sufficient
for semantics and we will come back to
that later
another interesting character is godel
godow's first incompleteness theorem
famously stated
that any effectively generated theory
capable
of expressing elementary arithmetic
cannot be both consistent
and complete in particular for any
consistent
effectively generated formal theory
f that proves certain basic arithmetic
truths
there is an arithmetic statement that is
true but not provable
in the theory and this can be used
almost anywhere and it's often referred
to as the god or sentence for a
particular theory
and it was used in anchor by roger
penrose he made the godelian argument
that
mathematical insight cannot be
computable he said that the mental
procedures whereby mathematicians arrive
at their judgments of truth are not
simply rooted in the procedures of some
specific formal system
and he followed up by saying human
mathematicians are not using a knowably
sound argument to ascertain
mathematical truth anyway i really hope
you enjoy the show today i'm absolutely
honored that mark came
on to discuss this with us i'm very
interested in the philosophy of ai in
the philosophy of mind
and make sure you read some of the
material that mark has signed posted and
i'll link those in the description
remember to like comment and subscribe
and we'll see you back
next week
welcome back to the machine learning
street talk youtube channel
and podcast with my two compadres mit
phd
dr keith duggar and alex basian
stenlake now today we are speaking with
mark
j bishop professor emeritus of cognitive
computing
at goldsmiths university of london mark
is interested in the philosophy of mind
and artificial intelligence
sorry that's my siri it seems to be very
interested in getting involved in this
conversation
mark is interested now it's playing
music because ai is stupid
that's why ai is really really stupid
and actually
that's a great segue for our
conversation today because because mark
our guest today also thinks that ai is
really really stupid but anyway
mark is interested in the philosophy of
mind and artificial intelligence and
rails
against what he calls computationalism
we'll get to that in a sec
machine consciousness and pan psychism
in 2010 mark was elected to the chair of
artificial intelligence and simulation
of behavior
which is the world's oldest ai society
he's been invited to advise on policy at
the un
the ec and also the uk government he's
published three academic books
200 articles and won three million
pounds worth of research funding
he serves as the associate editor of
nine international journals
and his research has spanned the
practice and theory of artificial
intelligence he's regularly asked to
comment on agi particularly in response
to these ai eschatologists of course we
were speaking about this a few weeks ago
so folks like hawkins and and musk and
kurzweil
who warn of an existential threat of
an intelligence explosion now in one of
mark's recent papers he concluded that
cognitivism
which is the whole idea of viewing the
brain as a computer and
its concomitant computational theory of
mind is inappropriate
and instead we should emphasize the role
of foundational processes such as
autonomy exploration autopiosis and
that's a strange word as well isn't it
so that means um a system capable of
reproducing and maintaining itself by
creating its own parts and eventually
uh further further components um and
social embeddedness
in giving rise to a genuine
understanding of our lived world
so in summary mark thinks that
computational theories of mind
cannot explain human cognition he thinks
that the claims of its research is that
you know genuine conscious mental states
can emerge
purely in virtue of carrying out a
specific series of computations he
thinks that those claims are egregious
now i discovered mark about a few months
ago because he's published this paper
called artificial intelligence
is stupid and causal reasoning won't fix
it
it's actually a really cool paper
because it's a tour de force of all of
the computational and philosophical
issues surrounding ai at the moment
and he kind of kicks off in the paper by
saying that ai is a brand tag it's
becoming ubiquitous but
a corollary of this is that there's
widespread commercial deployments where
ai gets things wrong
whether it's autonomous vehicle crashes
or chat bots being racist or
automated credit scoring you know
processes discriminating on gender
and of course we have a whole load of
people saying that we can improve it so
judea pearl and gary marcus
they say that deep learning is just
curve fitting it's just reasoning by
association
and uh you know if only we could build
computer systems that
um took things a step further and
thought about time and space and
causality
but mark takes the ai skepticism to a
whole new level because he thinks that
machines cannot
and will never understand anything
professor mark bishop welcome to the
show in your paper you talk about crick
and you talk about church and and
touring giving rise to computationalism
what do those folks say well in my paper
i start i start off with the idea that
it's become known as francis crick's
astonishing hypothesis that uh
you and everything that we are is are
defined by
um the certain particular set of neural
firing patterns any one instance
and if we take run with that idea to its
logical conclusion it would seem to be
that if we have an appropriately high
fidelity simulation
of just the brain we abstract from the
brain
with all the dirty chemicals the the
the neurotransmitters the serotonins and
the like we abstract away from all that
and just look at the neural firings
we've got everything everything else
drops out for free and a lot of people
surprisingly buy into this
uh to this idea and in fact it's one of
the uh
one of the hypotheses that that pushed
the
human brain projects and one of the
biggest european union um
funding uh grants of all time a few
years ago it was over a billion
foreign macrame and that
courted a lot of controversy with some
people saying with eu is putting a lot
of its eggs in one basket
and uh a lot of people had doubts as to
how much real science that programme
would um
would deliver and it hadn't died a very
interesting um
presentation to the group uh the libyan
brain project group
a number of years ago um because i was
arguing
um as tim outlined an introduction that
um we were not likely to get
conscious states in fact i think there
are good air priority arguments for
believing we won't get conscious states
of any computational simulation no
matter what that simulation is no matter
how fast it is
or no matter what algorithm it is unless
we have to bite the bullet and we accept
a very vicious form of pan psychism the
idea that
conscious phenomenal states are living
in everything the
very cup of tea of coffee that i'm
drinking at the moment
has its own mental states and the symbol
likes to pin my colours to the
scientific mask i find it somewhat
implausible to believe that my
coffee is is conscious of me drinking it
uh and so we're led to
to reject that horn and if we reject the
horn of uh
pansysm then unfortunately we're led to
in my opinion we led
to reject the idea that the mere
execution of a computer program can
bring full of conscious states
so that's kind of in a nutshell uh
the the executive summary if you like of
um
an argument i described as dancing with
pixies
that propose to show that unless we're
willing to accept panseikism
computers will never have phenomenal
states of consciousness
now that is a distinct argument from the
argument that people like sir mates that
says computers can't understand
and it's also distinct from people like
penrose who say there are certain
um things that people can do and pedro
is very famously talks about
mathematical insight that are
fundamentally non-computable
so it's my own minor contribution to the
debate and that is i don't believe that
computers can be conscious
unless we're willing to accept a very
nasty form and psychism
so i think some of that impulse right to
break things down you know and to find
the absolute minimum component that can
implement everything humor i mean that's
a very western kind of analytic
you know scientific approach to start
with and so if we don't want to throw
out
analytics as a whole like in what gap or
or let's say what do we need to add to
kind of artificial neurons
if you will in order to um or even to
the
computational paradigm itself so what do
we need to add to say the turing machine
or lambda calculus
you know concept in order to be able to
create
consciousness what's missing this
unfolds hugely complicated stories as
you can imagine
and i'm hoping that at some point in
time we'll get to go into
we'll engage in a little bit more depth
on what the dance is with pixi's
reduction
actually says because otherwise it just
sounds like a an airy hands-waving
philosophical statement that i'm making
it might be quite interesting to go into
the nuts and bolts of
why i believe that argument works but to
come back to keith's
point um like many people i think
working in the field
uh as a young teenager uh back in the
70s
i taught myself to program and had an
unhealthy interest in science fiction
and he put those two things together and
you're led to the
belief that i had very strongly as a
teenager that we would build
thinking conscious machines and that one
day they would
they would come to tyrannize mankind and
then slavers and go on to be the next
stage of evolution if you like
i'm not alone in that i'm sure many
people have had similar entertainment
similar fantasies
and it wasn't until i went to university
my choice of degree at university was
informed by these these
interests of mine peculiar interests of
a teenage male
and i went to read cybernetics at the
university of reading
it was the only place in the uk where
you could read cybernetics at the time
and that was a great uh education not
least as some of the people my tutor for
example alex andrews was one of the was
an
early first-round neural net pioneer
from the sort of 40s and 50s and
famously gave a couple of great papers
that the mechanization of thought
conference of people like minsky and
rosenblatt were all out
so i was surrounded by old school
academics who were from that first wave
of new uh
of people working in neural networks and
that was a really interesting place to
work
one of the guys that taught us um the
subnets is kind of an engineering and
it touches on all sorts of things but
we're sought in the uk was very much an
engineering discipline
and so one of the things we had to do
from year one was build
computers but not perhaps as you might
think of building a computer are you
going to get your board
and putting a few tips in perhaps but
literally starting out with ttl
and building your own half adder
building your own address decoders and
building literally
computer from individual ttl chips and
once you've done that you get a very
low level but real engineering
perspective of what's going on in the
computer
you don't tend to think anything too
fancy the idea that these things are
thinking machines start to become a bit
bizarre
um because you realize the machine has
no choice in what it does
if i imagine like a balance a ruler on a
pivot that's balanced
and press the ruler down one side the
other side comes up
it can't do anything but that and when
you see that the
operation of the logic gates in the
computer work in exactly the same way
uh that seems to be a very different
mode of oper
operation to that which we're used to
entertaining when we think about human
cognition
that said all those thoughts were
further down the intellectual line for
me
when i was engaging as an undergraduate
i'm just interested in building these
things
and i guess it wasn't until my third
year i was doing a joint degree in
science computer science and then
one of my lectures in computer science
was a guy went on to be professor of
theoretical computing at oxford
a girl called richard bird and he
introduced me to the notion of touring
non-computability
and um and also introduced me to gerd
lecture park but that's another tale
very interesting book which i'm sure
you're all very familiar with
and uh that was quite an intellectual
shock because prior to
doing that course i'd had this sort of a
very modest young man and i had this
idea that you give me a problem
and enough time and i'll i'll boss you
out the computer program that'll solve
it
and the idea that there could be
problems that were fundamentally
non-computable
was was a shock and it took a while for
that shop to actually seep in i was a
bit skeptical even though i knew what to
write to get
the reasonable mark in the exam i can't
say my heart was completely
wedded to the notion of
non-computability not least because the
proofs are these are kind of
weird as well when you get into them
there's lots of self-reference and
things and they seem a bit sort of
bizarre they did to me as a young
undergraduate anyway
but then roger penrose and i came back
to degree from phd
at reading um i was looking to meet
roger penrose uh
just around the time he was publishing
um the emperor's
new mind or just before that time and we
got chatting and i realized that my
intuitions about
the horror that non-computability might
pose we were being echoed by someone who
was
even at that time known as being a bit
of a polymath the guy that taught
stephen hawkins
amongst other things that worked with
him and the fact that this guy was also
echoing some serious reservations
that were based on gerdlinger my ideas
and based on chewing on computability he
stuck a chord with me
but the real big intellectual shock to
my uh again i started out with the pity
in neural networks with the intention of
building a thinking living breathing
conscious machine uh and then over that
period of doing that phd and
my position changed 180 degrees so after
meeting penrose the next big thing was i
went to a conference at oxford in 19 uh
god when would it be it was around the
time that uh parallel distributed
processing
first came out and ronald harper pulled
and came over for the first time
in the uk to describe back prop so this
is how
long ago it is i'm really quite
old-schooled in all these things so
yeah which is the first presentation
about proc at oxford
and it's a massive conference there was
you know it was a sellout conference for
the main room which probably held about
seven eight hundred was sold out they
had two overspill theatres
we were in the second of these overspill
theaters with video links
to the main stage and we heard these
presentations about prop which is all
very exciting but the thing that blew my
mind
having been brought up in an engineering
discipline cybernetics
was listening to two philosophers
because that was quite odd and there's
two philosophers with dinner and so
and i never heard a presentation like it
because unlike the sort of kind of
measured
dry presentations of how to control the
server mechanism or
a new algorithm for quicksort or
whatever the hell it happens to be in
our computer science and engineering
presentations
i assume that philosophers argue in a
much more
fisticuff kind of way and it was it was
a shock
um but also very engaging and uh and so
i came across
you know searle describing his chinese
room argument which
resonated with me at the time and and
hearing dana um
poopoo this at the time in his own
unique way
and um so around that time my thesis i
began to
uh entertain able to question where i
was going am i
and are my team and are people are there
people in the world who are doing
exciting things when you're all knows
are we going to build these thinking
machines
and gladly over that time and in the few
years that followed i reversed that
opinion
and the core intuition that drove all
that i guess really was
so chinese room argument no i think
you'll find a lot of sympathy
a lot of people that actually work you
know
very close to the ai or you know what's
referred to as ai when we're trying to
sell things
um you know we'll raise an eyebrow and
skepticism because you know we know gpt
is just a
big pile of linear algebra you know the
the talk about the transformational
effects really come from the business
side
you're among good company here but to
kind of go back you said you wanted to
touch on this dancing with pixies
yeah argument that you raised earlier
and this kind of links into the the
notions of pan psychism
and how this relates to you know if you
if you want to take the idea that a
computer can be intelligent that it can
think that it can understand things
then you end up concluding that anything
can
kind of have this you run us through the
like very briefly people haven't read
the paper
pan psychism argument the dancing with
pixies fallacy and
kind of like how this all kind of flows
into the conclusion that
computers cannot be intelligent yeah one
of the axioms in which this argument is
built is the idea that computation
is not on objective fact of the world
it's observer relative so i first
want to give you a couple of examples
that i think will underscore that axiom
one because a lot of people would reject
that's a nonsense
computation what a computer does is a
fact of the matter
so again i'll go back to my
undergraduate days when we had to build
um before we use ttl we literally have
to build these logical gates out of
transistors
so it doesn't get much more basic than
that
so imagine you built some a set of
transistors to
perform the following electronic logic
you have
two inputs to the circuit and one output
call inputs a and b and the output
if both inputs a and b are 0 volts
the output is 0 volts if a is
five volts and b is zero the output is
zero if a
is zero volts and b is five the output
is zero if
a and b are five volts the output is
five volts
what logical function guys is that
performing
and you might be right
it's performing and if we assume that
naught volts is false
and 5 volts is true now if i tell you
that you are actually wrong in your
assumption that nor false was true
and five volts with false what logical
function is that performing
nand oh who remembers their bullying
there we go
oh that's right it's performing or not
so in other words the computational
function
this bit of electronics is doing
is contingent on the on the observer
relative
mapping between the electronics and the
world
right if i use a naught volts false five
volts three mapping
it does an and if i use the universe of
that it's doing an
or you cannot tell a martian from planet
mong couldn't look at that and say
that's an and gate that's an all gate
without knowing that mapping and that
mapping
is subjective i might have one mapping
alex might have another keith might
have another one in fact a a great uh
israeli scientist orange extends this
argument
pathologically and looks at multi-level
logics and the problem gets
really weird if you go down that route
but i'll just stick to the simple case
with the and the orphans
so that's one reason why i said
fundamentally i mean it seems to be just
axiomatic i just baffled when people
tell me this is not the case but i'd
still occasionally meet people who
dispute
it so there's a second follow-through
argument
and it's it's built on the work of uh
winograd
and flores in their book understanding
computers and cognition
when they start to think about what is a
world a word processor and i've reframed
their argument
a little and i think about what is a
chess program
i know that any of you guys are old
enough to remember in the 70s we used to
have these little
chess plastic chest computers that on a
square
they had little holes on on a bit of
board and little tiny little chassis
plastic chess pieces and the light when
you made your move you lifted piece up
and popped it where you wanted to go and
then the computer would light up the
piece
you had to move and where that was to go
using one of these gadgets you could i
could quite happily play i'm not very
good chessboard so
i could happily get thrashed by these
machines day in day out and
and enjoy that thrashing so to say speak
and i could argue that i could use that
piece of computational equipment to play
chess with now in the uk
there's there's a famous conceptual
artist by the name of tracy evan who
does a lot of work with neons i don't
know whether you guys have
come across at work at all and also in
the 60s
there was a big movement in what's
called kinetic art where you're in
cybernetic art where people interacted
with art pieces
so now what unbeknownst to me tracy's
sabotaged my
test computer she's ripped the innards
out and she's now wired all the inputs
to pressure pads in an art exhibition in
an art gallery and all the outputs to
neon
strips so when people walk over these
pressure pads
different neon lights come on and off
now there was no sense that you can
possibly it seems to me that you could
possibly say
that when i walk around the art gallery
i'm playing chess
i'm interacting with a bizarre piece of
abstract art
certainly not playing chess so it
doesn't seem to me there's anything
intrinsically chess like in this device
yes it was engineered very carefully so
that uh
if i knew what i was doing i could play
chess with it but i could use it in
other ways as well
um and the problem gets even worse if
you've come across isomorphic games
um let's imagine probably those notes
and crosses
now uh imagine you've got a um
a knots and crosses game on your on your
iphone and you've got a like i have a
six-year-old daughter who's just
just about got a head around knots and
plotters i can keep her occupied for
i was gonna say half an hour without the
exaggeration for five minutes say
giving her this thing and she'll play
notes and crosses happily against and
says
oh daddy i'm bored what am i gonna do so
ah well i've got another game i can show
you
but she says daddy you've only got one
game on a computer so i'm going to play
it against the computers
don't worry about that we've got the
nuts and crosses i've got another game
i'm going to call it
um computer whisk now imagine you lay
the car
the deck of cards out ace through to
no uh nine and
you we take it in turns to pick cards
from this deck
the winner is the first person who can
get 15.
get cards to 7 to 15. it transpires that
if you've got a program that can play
notes and crosses with a suitable
mapping
you can get it to play a perfect game of
computer whisk so given the grid it's
like a magic square
where all the verticals horizontal and
diagonals add up to 15
right you then plot your computer go
it's marking your one square
choose your go it tells you which card
to pick next you can
play a perfect game of computer with so
i can use that same computer program
with my mapping to play a perfect gaming
computer with
so you cannot say in advance without
knowing what i'm going to do with that
program whether i'm going to play
tic-tac-toe or computer-wise
so i think those three arguments
together make to me a persuasive case
to paraphrase wittgenstein that the
meaning of a computation
is in its use by human computer users
the phrase though as you want to you're
all aware from fitness and paraphrasing
it's one of the investigations where it
makes the claim that the meaning of a
word is its use in by human plays with
human language games
and i think the sum applies to
computation the meaning of a computation
lies in the use that we as human
uh users of computers put that to so
that's
that's kind of setting the stage so i
think there's always going to be this
mapping at the physical level
and then there's always the idea of what
we're going to use a computation to do
and that's a very social
human activity so that's setting the
state where i want to go with advancing
the pixies now the next move i make
i know you'll have all have read
computing machinery and intelligence
during
famous 1950 paper everyone's
at least looked through this and whether
touring first outlined a turing test
what became known as
turin test also in that paper he
outlines the operation of a very simple
machine turing's discrete state machine
as it became known and this is a
beautifully simple machine it's a disc
light device
and it can go around in 120 degree
intervals
and it can stop at the 12 o'clock the 8
pm and the 4 pm position as it moves
around
a clock and it can exist in each one of
those discrete positions
and we can describe that the operation
of that machine
as a as a finite state automaton if the
machine's in state a and the next clock
ticket is going to go to b
if it's a b next cocktail is going to go
to c and if it's at c
it'll go back to a again now
if we want to we can um arrange that
when the machine is in computational
state a
it will do something when it's in
computational stability you'll do
something
cheering in vegeta when it's in
computational state a a light would come
on
you also imagine there being simple
input to the machine like a big lever
break mechanism that you could have on
or off
so if the machine was in state and the
brake was on it would remain in state
that if it breaks off it would go to
state b
one of the first interesting things that
we again like computation you see the
copy
when you're given a turing discrete
state machine
to read off the computational state abc
we need a mapping between the physical
position of the
lever machine and the computer
rotational state to which it refers so
we may define
computational state a to be the 12
o'clock position in which case when the
lever is there
we're in a or we move it so it's at b
and the wrestling follow super we always
need that
that mapping we've always got to do
these mappings between
the physics of what's going on and the
computational state that we're
instantiating
so now we've got this machine uh without
the brake it just goes through a b
abc abc abc abc
uh and that's interesting enough if
you're interested in input this finite
state automaton they're not very
exciting machines all they can do
do is go through a cyclic series of
states forever in an unbranching
series of state transitions
well what was interesting is that uh in
the appendix to hillary putnam's
representation in reality
is a little known proof this shows
how we can effectively how we can map
the operation of any
uh um input this finite state automata
onto a large digital counter actually
putting them goes further
and shows that we can map it on to the
opera on to any open physical system
an open physical system being a physical
system that's open to gravitational
waves and
all the rest of it uh electromagnetic
spectrum and binding onto it
but for simplicity let's just consider
the without water generality let's just
imagine we can
map the operation of any input this fsa
onto a bloody large
uh digital counter how does put them do
that well let's take chewing's machine
it just says if the
computation is in state a i'm going to
map that to the digital counter state
zero zero
zero if it's in state b i'll map that to
counter state one if it's in st
in state composition state c i'll map
that to counter state two
and then the a again we'll go to three b
again we'll go to four and see we're
gonna go to five and then we get over
any finite time period
we can replicate the state transitions
of our digital
uh discrete state machine by the numbers
that
we're cycling through on our digital
counter
and again you might answer so so what
that um
that doesn't seem particularly
threatening result for computationalism
at first sight
because real computations much more
complex
devices than inputless finite state
automata
well in uh in a paper called does a rock
implement every
input that's fine i say automated david
chalmers responds to this argument in in
an interesting way
and uh he says that yeah i'll concede if
you like that we can implement
really trivial machines like this
financial automata using putnam's
mapping but when we want to
look at machines with input this breaks
down
because we get a combinatorial explosion
of states that we need and
chalmers introduces a very neat uh
construction called the combinatorial
state automata
which we can implement using putnam's
mapping but an exponential increase the
number of states that we need and the
combinatorial state automata is
sensitive
to initial conditions and so could be
genuinely said if we could implement it
with an infrastructure
could generally be said to be
implementing a computation with input
but at the cost of every time step of
the computational you need an exponent
your number of states grows
exponentially and chalmers makes the
point that
after a very short number of states will
run out of the number states needed is
bigger than the number of atoms in the
known
universe and hence putting them as a
mapping must fail
and that's kind of where i entered the
debate because i made an incredibly
trivial
uh all the all the hard work been done
long before i came
to play with this game so to speak but
my only trivial
uh modification to putnam's argument
that to me makes it robust
the charm as it says is to say this well
if we look at
any real machine of which it's claimed
has
genuine mental states conscious states
as it interacts with the world
and this this intuition was brought real
for me because again some people dispute
the fact there are people who believe
that
there are serious scientists who believe
in the machine consciousness program
they definitely are and i used to my
header department
at reading cybernetics was one of those
people a guy called kevin warwick
and we reading and built these little
simple uh
robots that moved around a corral
controlled by a neural network
and kevin said well these got roughly
the center of neurons as a slogan it's
pure human bias if you say a slug
has conscious experience and these
robots didn't and i thought that was a
ludicrous
claim and that inspired me to move and
develop this uh
dancing olympics is reductio so to come
back to the case
i said right then kevin if you say your
robot as it moves around like a chorale
over a
finite time window t1 to tk experience
is something that it is like to be a
robot bundling around the corral not
bumping into things
i don't know what that is but let's just
imagine it has some conscious experience
what i what i can do is log
all the inputs to that machine
and then i'll play them back to them so
i now lifted the rubber out the corral
i've disconnected all its
uh sensors if you like in actuators and
i'm just injecting into the robot the
the states it would have got were it
whizzing around the corral on its sound
says to go and does the machine still
have conscious state well yeah of course
it has it's
it's reading the numbers from a latch
the number the data was originally taken
from an 80d converter for argument's
sake
we're now plonking that data in there
from injection system
but the computer still has the
phenomenal states and so kevin warwick
asserted
and that unfortunately that to the
problem that he was going to encounter
because if that was the case
all that we're really into we can take
we can collapse the exponentially
growing number of states that chalmers
showed we would have if you actually
want to implement fully all aspects of
the computation
using putnam's mapping if we just try to
look at the particular computational
trace
we just need the inputs to that machine
that pertained to any
over time as the machine did its little
thing and then we can remove all the
counter factual states
and once we've done that we've got a
linear series of state transitions that
we can reliably map
using putnam's mapping and hence if it's
the case that kevin warrick's little
robot was conscious
then so must our account to be conscious
and then after
putting any open physical system so
now in a nutshell is is the dwp
reduction
it's interesting that in a lot of these
seminal debates
to me about ai about penn notes about
serving about my own small contribution
there's a lot of confusion people can
very easily misinterpret what's been
saying
a lot of people got hung up about does a
rock genuinely implement a computation
you know and i think to me tom has
completely proved that it does not
right no problem with that can we make a
rock with a suitable mapping
implement an arbitrary series of state
transitions
yes i think we can and i think we can
make any count to do that
and because we always use a mapping
whatever system we use i don't think i'm
doing anything there's no slight of hand
involved here because all computational
systems involve
an observer relative mapping somewhere
along the line to get them to work
whether it's only assigning a logical
truth to five volts and a logical false
to naught volts
so i don't think the use of a mapping is
something that you know and there's no
sleight of hand involved
in that given that i confused an
arbitrary complex series of state
transitions
so then the question is if you're a
physicalist and i would approach this
problem originally as someone who you
know i like to think of myself as if i'm
not a mysterious i don't want to appeal
to some supernatural forces to bring
forth my consciousness
and at one point in time it was the case
that well if you don't believe in
functionalism or
computationalism then you've got to
believe in supernatural effects well
that is no longer the case
cognitive science has moved on a lot
since the 1960s there's an awful lot of
new tools in town and these are really
exciting tools in my
my viewing highlighted a few in the
introduction tim but things like the
embodied and active embedded and
ecological approaches can go a long way
to
answering or giving his insights into
these questions without having to bring
forth
particularly supernatural notions so i'm
going to put that to one side we don't
we're no longer faced with a choice of
either
accept computationalism or accept
putnam's rock i mean there's a lot of
interesting responses to it but i want
to
point out a couple things or maybe just
ask you about a couple things so
one thing is that uh first i think what
your goal
is and correct me if i'm wrong with the
the pixie dancing with pixies argument
is to say simply that if we accept
um uh say turing complete computation or
even in this case finite state machines
but i think we can probably go one step
further if we accept that effectively
computable systems
can implement consciousness then we also
have to accept
uh pan psychism correct that's that's
what i
try to show right um because once you
have a system that you that you play
like
my boss kevin said that machine is
conscious
right i can look at what happens if that
machine interacts with the world
and log all the inputs to it i can trace
the flow of the execution flow of that
of the machine code that control the
robot and then i can implement that's a
an arbitrary series of state
transactions that's another that would
do exactly that with an appropriate
mapping
with a digital media digital camera so
if that machine is conscious
then my digital accounting would plus
this mapping must be conscious
right so that's the position i arrived
at now when i'm chatting to david
chalmers about this and he said oh no no
no no no
you've gone off the road because we need
the full
potential of the computation to be there
for functionalism to hold
now this is quite a mysterious view in
fact it was so mysterious that when he
first said
he had to repeat it about three times
because i'm not the quickest to uptake
and i found it
so bloody bizarre what he was saying but
when i did unpick what he was saying
the chalmers you actually need uh
once you effectively slice off the
potential counterfactual actions by
saying well
i know the input at this point in time i
know the input of that i'm going to
replace the counter factuals in my
program by
direct go to statements if you like or
just just
snip them from the from the program to
me that couldn't possibly
affect the phenomenal state of the
system because otherwise you're saying
that non-entered branches of a computer
program
right have a causal effect on the
phenomenal state of your machine
but the bizarre thing is that's what
david said said no
that's it you've got to have the
potential for counterfactuals there
otherwise we don't have phenomena we
don't have the machine generally
instantiating phenomenal states
so if we just if we just assume in argue
window that
people don't or that we don't accept pan
psychism
okay and that and that that these
arguments prove that if we accept
computationalism it implies you know
pan psychism okay we also have
mathematical results that say
um let's say turing computation or
effective computation
encompasses all computation like there
is no you know there is no other kind of
computation
unless there's hyper computation right
and so i think what we're saying
i believe and correct me if i'm wrong
but i believe what we're saying is that
there exists
hyper computation and that human minds
are performing
hyper computation so just just take this
back to the rock for a second
one issue with that mapping right is
that rocks actually have
physical states that may be real numbers
you know they they may have values that
in and of themselves are not computable
you know they can have positions and
states and quantum states that
that have values that are essentially
defined by an infinite precision real
number and therefore are not even
accessible
to computability to start with like even
describably right
so are we saying because i'm always
looking for where consciousness is
hiding
if you will like are we saying that it's
hiding in
sort of real valued states you know
maybe quantum states like penrose would
say perhaps some microtubules or
something like that you know
is that is that a form of hyper
computation and is that where our
consciousness derives from
where do we draw the dividing line
because that's something that
that's like i've read quite a few of
your papers in preparation as you do
when you're going to speak with someone
um and this dividing line where we go
from you know
computational and essentially impossibly
into
like impossible to achieve intelligence
or understanding or any measure thereof
to the point where we have an an
intelligent system that can understand
its world and
and sort of redefine itself and redefine
its world
um that distinction is is not terribly
clear and i
as we dive into this question i want to
drive towards where this distinction
lies
if this distinction exists well to pick
up on keith's point
first i think i'm i'm neutral i mean
penrose has given a positive
thesis as well as a negative one so
famously in the emperor's new mind he
gives
he gives he gives his first version of
the goodly
the an argument that reports to show
that mathematical insights
non-computable and then
says well this suggests to me that
non-computability lies at the heart of
what it is to be human and then with
stuart hamroff they outlined a positive
thesis which
which proposed to show that
non-computability can arise in the brain
through
the orchestrated collapse quantum
collapse in the microtubule skeleton
of brain neurons i'm perhaps
neutral on this i know that when
penerose held a psych symposium on his
work
in 1995 and it attracted a lot of
responses
well over 20 friend and brightly and i
don't think any of his logical work
was seriously brought into question so
the that
is his interpreter even though that was
actually a naive interpretation of
google
compared to the work that he put out in
shadows of the mind he's a much more
nuanced
uh uh approach to the argument in my
opinion but nonetheless
it wasn't seriously criticized nearly
everybody criticized his positive thesis
so i'm yeah penrose is a clever guy it
seems interesting i'm not going to hang
my colours onto that flag
particularly if it works great but i'm
i've been more drawn to modern
approaches to cognitive science which
look at uh at the end and you know there
isn't unfortunately a very quick
six-page paper that can can lead people
gently into this but there are
four schools that all this work really
started out with working for roboticism
mit
called rodney brooks who wrote a
classical paper which you guessed you
guys are familiar with
called intelligence without
representation which basically goes to
you senator tommy
when i did robotics old-fashioned
old-school representational robotics as
a young postgrad
a lot of our work was trying to build
take data from sensors and build rich
internal models of an out their world
and remember we
we spent all our budget on buying this
biggest fattest computers we could
possibly afford at the time and
strapping them onto these poor little
autonomous vehicles and they were laden
down with computer power
and they moved absolutely tragically
slowly we're going back in
in the early 90s now but they were they
were pathetically slow things you know
really embarrassingly bad
because a lot of their work was trying
to build up these models looking we're
trying to build mothers of them now i
know that
these days we can do that kind of thing
bloody quickly but back in the day you
couldn't and and brooks thought well do
we need to do it
and in that paper he argued that we
didn't why build the representation we
can use the world as its own
representation
and in in a sense that sort of paved the
way for thinkers like um
francisco varela then in a book called
the embodied mind
with evan thompson and anandaraj
to to start thinking about different
ways of doing cognitive science and and
the embodiment is a mind-blowing book
it's a
it's quite a ah it throws your
your whole view in the same in a in an
to go to leicester park can be quite
mind-blowing as a as a young kid this is
mind-blowing as well but in a
in the kind of a weirder way because it
actually questions the existence of a
fixed pre-given out their world
and that was quite a shock to me when i
first came across these ideas not being
a trained continental philosopher that
my first mode of engagement was with
varela who
incidentally started out as a
theoretical biologist and then someone
very active in the a life community so i
think his
initial work has also been from a
sciencey perspective but he engaged
quite deeply with uh with the european
philosophy which which at that point in
my life i was
totally ignorant of and so this led to a
development of alternative schools of
what cognition is all about
then the inactive skill is one that i'm
interested in and it says that you know
um effectively we can look at one sort
of
the nationality itself is these days
split into
numerous sub approaches uh
one of these from developed by a guy
called kevin
reagan and alvin airy argue that uh
visual consciousness is something that
we do
so they're moving away from the idea
that vision is like
interpreting like the eye getting the
scene from the world on your brain
having some
little like uh uh cinema which you're
then
interpreting what all these little bits
do they make the case that the vision is
more akin to an activity is what we do
it's guided sensory motor exploration of
the world
rather itself is particularly interested
in uh embroidering ideas of autonomy how
how can how can things become meaningful
there's all these very complicated
debates that i think to try and come
back to your question keith and your
question alex
we you need to touch on but it's really
challenging to
to try to turn them in an intelligible
way in a relatively short period of time
you would you would at least agree
though that um you know your
contribution penrose etc
points very strongly that there's
something
embodied there's something physical that
we haven't quite figured out yet maybe
it's microtubules maybe it's something
else you're agnostic to that
but there's something physical that
allows my intuition is to do with
autonomy
uh and this is why we're bringing the
idea of ultra policies and that tim
mentioned at the beginning that auto
breezes is a again
in the 70s zumba to achieve the chilean
side musicians alberto machurano and
francisco varela came up with a
theoretical
device for delineating life and non-life
because astonishingly
this has been a really difficult problem
you'd think it was probably solved
hundred years ago it hasn't been and
even as recently as when margaret bone
was writing on this one school
tried to say life is and then give
enumerated a list of properties
it has to metabolize it has to reproduce
bloody bloody blood
and maturana looked it from a different
perspective well what fundamentally
life is a system that has a circular
organization it's got to be able to
maintain its own boundary
of itself and the other and it has to
encapsulate the rules the automatic
rules that maintain that boundary
in the face of a changing environment
we spoke to um uh fristen carl fristen
quite recently and he was talking about
markov blankets which is quite
interesting about how do you define the
the boundaries of a physical system and
you know does a hurricane have a mark of
boundary and
what we're talking about here in a very
general sense is defining boundaries
between what lives and what doesn't live
and
what is meaning and what isn't meaning
and what is understanding and what isn't
understanding
and it's very philosophical it's quite
difficult to pin this down
if you look at uh materano and varala's
book it's about
60 pages their original treatment uh
autophages and cognition from
from the 70s and it is very dense it's
it's it's it's not a waffly
philosophical book it's quite
hardcore quite mathematical yeah i think
they
they do do an interesting job at pinning
down
uh what uh if you like what it might be
for something to be alive
and this has been this challenge which
was explored in in the embodied mind
has since been developed by evan
thompson who's a
an american american but uh
an interesting philosopher who wrote a
book called mind in life
where uh the argument is laid out that
there's a that life is a continuum and
wherever have you a
uh this continuum of life then you have
a proto mentality
and i'm kind of drawn to that i think
it's a very persuasive argument
and um then
we have to look at the question of what
constitutes autonomous systems
and why should it matter if an
autonomous system has a
phenomenal sense of what it is like to
be
um here if you like you can link into
the work of a guy i've just recently
come across who wrote to me a few weeks
ago
uh he used to run a big lab in france
a.i love in france
mikhail i think his his name is and he
he argues that we need phenomenal
consciousness
to arbitrate between
uh different actions if you're sending a
robot to a mars it absolutely has got to
be completely autonomous and it's got to
react appropriately
in different in in unknown environments
all sorts of different threats
effectively the robot's going to have to
know
something in its state that it's good to
be that makes the robot feel
pleasant in a state that's horrible it's
danger that might cause
death to the robot it has to that we use
the phenomenal
sense of what that feels like we can
then use that to arbitrate
between different actions and this is
actually by the way
as an audience i first came across
through a paper by daniel dennett
called cognitive wheels the frame
problem of ai
when he looks at what must be known to
us to
arbitrate on what he called the cookie
problem imagine you've got
a big jar of cookies and some little
kids like my six-year-old daughter
two families one next to each other in
one family when the child goes for a
cookie
the family beats it smacks it
relentlessly until it's in tears and
never goes
it doesn't have any more cookies after
that and the other one they they're very
sort of touchy feeling oh no please
don't have another
cookie tarquin and occasionally talking
just go and have another cookie
denna asks the question why is it that
beating your kid
causes that child not to go for the
cookie jar anymore
and we know that well because being
beaten is something deeply unpleasant
and uh you don't particularly unless
your metacats want to
do things that are going to bring this
feeling of pain about you
but then then they said well how do we
know that we can we can
we can arbitrarily hard wire such facts
in
so i could hardwire into my computer
program if
something else biffs me then i'm gonna
i'll increase my pain by one and if
pain gets over a certain threshold i
won't do that action again
that's incredibly brittle it's literally
arbitrary but unless we have
phenomenality unless we have access to
phenomenal states and know that
getting bift hurts or going over rough
terrain if you're a marginal robot
takes you around a bit you you have to
just sidestep that by hard wiring
effectively hard coding
because as engineers the system is no
longer autonomous now we're having to
define what it has to do for all these
different
possible states that's the price we have
to pay
so i think you can argue that
evolutionism
has blessed us with phenomenal
consciousness
so that we can act autonomously and
that's the way that
i guess after evan thompson and varela
and
the view that i i come to so we need
consciousness to to enable us to succeed
evolutionarily
well haven't we just fallen foul of the
fir the kind of prime
axiom of software engineering at this
point that you know every problem is
just a level of abstraction away
because i mean we could you know i
forget which paper it was you had a
really great uh
conclusion in one of your papers where
you essentially said if we built a bunch
of robots that looked and behaved
just like us their automata they they
laugh at our jokes they respond but the
thing that defines
like the difference here or the
difference between us and them would be
that you know when when we're laughing
and feeling we feel it it's
phenomenological
when they do it it's not it's a
simulation but you know
leading into this argument it's like
well to have these martian robots that
have
autonomy and can succeed they need to
have this phenomenological state
isn't this isn't this really just a
software engineering problem away from
being solved
i i think when i wrote that paper i was
i mean certainly very recently literally
and i i want to i'm hoping to to work or
at least to
reach out to mikhail to see if we can do
something together so i'm quite excited
by these
essays this sent me i think they make up
his i don't know why i just haven't
occurred to me that this
could be a reason why consciousness has
has evolved he makes a very persuasive
case
i'd love to claim it was my idea but it
absolutely isn't but i think it's a very
beautiful one
i need to understand more and either he
will push it or perhaps he might do
something together i don't know
um but yeah so i i i'm a little bit
skeptical that
without that the glue of consciousness
that we could get a machine
to act as a symbol chrome of you in all
possible
cases um i was arguing from the stronger
i guess in that paper well let's just
assume that we can i think
engineering-wise i'm a little bit
skeptical now i'm following mikhail's
work that that
is going to be possible but also to come
back to another point
uh that relates to the are we going to
talk about the chinese room with all or
are you assuming that's boring for your
readers
no no i think that's one of the most
important things because because we're
we're talking now about you know
consciousness and the various different
kind of
boundaries between what is and what is
not consciousness but i think the other
one is really important is understanding
and the boundaries between what is and
what isn't understanding you say in one
of your papers what does it mean for a
central processing unit to understand
does it understand the program and its
variables in a manner analogous to sales
understanding
of this rule book but this sells rule
book thing right it describes a
procedure as you say in one of your
papers that if carried out accordingly
um allows cell to participate in an
exchange of uninterrupted symbols
squiggles and squoggles
which to an outside observer look as if
so is accurately responding in chinese
to questions
in chinese about stories in chinese in
other words it appears as if so in
following his rule book actually
understands chinese
even though seoul trenchantly continues
to insist that he does not
understand a word of the language so
this has been used i think very reliably
and
you had a paper actually recently
introducing a couple of other responses
because there were
four responses to sales argument right
there was the robot reply the system's
reply the brain simulator reply
the combination reply and in your recent
paper you talked about
um robots and animats in the target bbs
article there was a lot more than fault
so when he wrote the paper came up with
four possible counter arguments which
are the classic ones
that tim just outlined but from memory
there must have been over 20 people
really big names in philosophy and ai
who responded
to that bbs target article people like
marvin minsky
mccarthy uh denna obviously
uh uh god i can't
the shanties have forgotten but that
big big names uh who are different
responses there's a lot more
than the four that so but i mentioned
these because
what's been bizarre having uh
i edited today with john preston we
edited
on the 20th 21st anniversary of the
chinese room argument
john preston and i put together an
edited collection of responses to it
twenty year one years on from leading
ai scientists cognitive scientists and
philosophers
and i still think that's a good
collection of essays that we that we
picked and good collection of people to
contribute to that volume
and then again in the intervening years
between this chinese room argument
coming out and that volume coming out
and then between that volume coming out
in 2002 and
now really and i've talked about this in
as you can imagine
in many places most of the uk
universities and quite a few in
in europe and one or two in america and
nearly all there is
the most formidable responses that i've
come across
really go back to the responses that sir
actually
predicted and by far the most common and
probably the most
i think the strongest response is is
some variant on what became known as the
system's reply
that you that you mentioned him can you
just quickly define what the system's
reply is
do you mind if i just just go over again
because he went over really really
quickly the essence of the argument but
i'd like just to sort of unpack it
slightly more slowly
so sir imagine so to set the scene
cell's a monoglot english speaker
shamefully like myself shamefully
because i'm married to a greek lady
i still can pretty well only communicate
in english
at best and um the soul can as well so
he imagines himself
locked in a room and this room has got
effectively got a letterbox
instead of a door to which he could
communicate with the outside world and
in the room with three piles
of papers and on these papers
are strange symbols that serve doesn't
know what they are we know
there's people reading about the
experiment hearing about it that these
are actually chinese idiographs but to
sew
they're just uninterpreted squiggles and
squiggles you've got no idea what they
are
so you've got these three piles of
things and on the desk there's a big
grimoire a book that tells sirl how to
correlate the symbols from the first
power with symbols on the second
and then other rules that time out to
correlate symbols on the first parallel
and with the second part
and also linking symbols on the third
parallel another rules that tell him how
to take symbols to one of these piles
and stick them
to people uh through their throats to
the outside world
well unbeknownst to so the first panel
defines
a script uh the second in chinese the
second panel describes a story in
chinese and the third part describes
questions about that story in chinese
and the symbol soul was told by the book
to give to people in the outside world
answers to questions for that story in
chinese and sales point is that if we
concede so he's arguing again from the
strongest it says okay let's concede
but that rule book however it's defined
and again a lot of people got home
because they thought so was
purely talking about a naive pattern
matching program if this symbol doesn't
then do that actually still makes it
clear if you read the paper carefully
that he wants us to stand for any
conceivable computer program
this was the first reaction that i had i
had an allergic reaction to it because
as we know from talking to walid suburb
you know that we can't write the damn
compiler
for language it's too complicated so
it's not possible really for even us to
explicitly understand and verbalize the
rules that we use in language and you
said yourself that
artificial intelligence practitioners
were incredulous at the extremely kind
of you know simplistic
uh view of cell that you could have this
um
you know low level rules described
yeah but i mean if that's because they
didn't read the paper carefully
because cell makes it absolutely
explicit that he generalizes
he gives a simple example to sort of
just get you thinking about the problems
and imagine
as again so this is the world that you
know some people have tried to do
language into
understanding in this very naive way but
sir wants the
uh thought of the stand for any possible
program all we're doing is
the rule book tells cell how to
manipulate uninterpreted symbols
and put uninterpreted symbols out of the
door uh how it does that whether it's
implementing a neural network whether
it's sometimes geogetic algorithm
whether it's implementing valid uh uh
sense based uh uh uh
word effect sentence-based word direct
compositional understanding natural
language designing
whether it's doing uh uh gpt-3 kind of
operations it's irrelevant
still says whatever your program is
that's what's in the book
and at the end of the day that program
will tell me how to respond to questions
in chinese with answers in chinese if i
follow that
program uh carefully don't make any
mistakes i'll give answers out the door
if your program's any good
it will give answers that are
indistinguishable from those a natural
and native speaking chinese person would
give even though as seoul transitionally
insists
i following this program as not in order
to get even the toefl
in chinese semantics all i've been doing
is like a
mega fast idiot's evolving manipulating
uninterpreted symbols around
and sticking some symbols i don't know
what the hell they are through a
letterboxing and that to the outside
world
does that imply then that it's just
observationally
impossible to determine whether a black
box is conscious
well this is a i wrote a a counter
argument to susan
i can't pronounce it now probably these
uh
cheering test for machine consciousness
why i make that exact claim
um this was in frontiers and
robotics or one of the frontiers
journals a couple of years ago
because susan says oh we can ask her
ideas we if we ask
questions that are about particularly
human activities relating to phenomenal
experience we'll be able to tell whether
this machine is
uh she gives a procedure um for doing
this
i would say well do whatever set of
questions susan you have for deciding
whether your machine is conscious i'm
going to sit
unbeknownst to you and what you ask them
i'm then going to go away and write a
little
program in basic because i'm good at
writing in basic
that says if question one says bloody
bloody blah are you susan's first
question
give this answer which is the answer
that a really complicated
machine consciousness program gave so in
fact have a look at the table
but because susan doesn't know because i
sneakily
switch the machine so she asks her
questions thinking she's talking to a
really complicated machine
consciousness thing she asks the
questions which she claims will tell her
whether this machine is conscious but
she's actually just
interrogating with a really simple up
thing and at the end they give us the
answers she wants us yeah that's
conscious
but she's just been talking to a look-up
table it's yeah i think that
you're quite right keith i think it
isn't obvious to me
how we're going to be able to do a test
for machine consciousness purely on the
basis of external observation
in the absence of anything else because
we cannot if we're machiavellian we can
always uh
cheat the thing is when you were talking
about it doesn't have semantics i want
to one pick that a little bit as well
because
you said the robot rover on mars uh
the the semantics there were there's the
state spaces of all of the sensory
experiences and then you said it's
brittle and there's an alignment problem
and
i can understand that it's very similar
to the the ai alignment argument
but this is different if you
if you can replicate let's say you're
talking to a black box and you can't
distinguish whether or not
it has consciousness or whether it has
understanding
why is there an issue with semantics in
that case
ah you're wrong for me i thought you're
going to say how can i tell that anybody
understands or is conscious which is
actually one of the core
uh responses that's all um anticipated
in the chinese
that that is actually that is the
obvious question as well like
presumably do you think that we are
conscious because we might exist in a
computer simulation right
well i i don't think we can because i
don't i i know that if i
slap my face it hurts right and i yeah i
know
that machines can't instantiate
phenomenal consciousness i made a paper
called
a ref refuting digital ontology which is
after
an invited talk at the royal society
workshop on the incomputable
hosted by barry cooper who was the
leader of the cheering centenary
celebrations in the uk and worldwide
and um i made this very argument then
that i don't it isn't
obvious to me i think that it's clearly
obvious to me that we're not in a
computer simulation
because i feel and if my
dancing with pictures reduce your
argument is correct unless i'm willing
to accept antagonism
and computations can't realize sensation
so either my dancing with pixie's
reduction is wrong in which case i'm
very
i'll be sad but in the instance i'll be
happy when you show me where i'm going
wrong
um or if i'm right then we're not living
in a computer simulation so
i i don't think we are in computer
simulations furthermore it's an axiom of
cognitive science that other minds exist
so it's not for me to have to explain
why i believe that you three guys
have phenomenal conscious states that's
part of cognitive sciences is
is acknowledging that you do and trying
to come up with a theory that explains
why these occur and how they occur the
conscious state argument to kind of
perhaps play devil's advocate a bit here
um
to me when i first came across the
dancing with pixie's argument
this wasn't an argument that for me
implied rocks had understanding or
intelligence to me it implied that
that we don't there's nothing that
that has intelligence or understanding
right what nutrition i wanted you to
come to is that computation
doesn't have those phenomenal
consciousness states
i actually the argument again
interestingly what a reviewer said this
of one version i think of the 2009
computing paper aren't you arguing too
strongly
doesn't this prove that nothing can have
consciousness no it doesn't
it just says that the the operation of a
digital computer
a finite state automata to be uh
to pin it down more precisely cannot
give rise to conscious experience unless
conscious experience is in everything
that's all it says now if you don't bite
the bullets it will actually i think i'm
more than a finite state automaton thank
you very much alex there's more to me
i'm an embodied entity
well i i don't just think in my brain i
think with my body
and my body in the world and again
there's a beautiful result that came
from a guy and i'm going to
argue as a professor at goldsmiths and
i'm going to take his work and
and extend it probably in ways that he
he would be uncomfortable so this is my
interpretation
of work that's published in a number of
papers in nature by jules davidov
on colour perception by the hindu tribe
uh
in his work in africa i'll just describe
this beautiful expression because i
would argue
jules is a very cautious academic and he
doesn't make wild proclamations
that i'm more comfortable doing uh
looking at his work but basically jill's
did this beautiful
set of experience over a long period of
time working with the hepatitis
color perception and when i first saw
them again they blew my mind because
they
basically appeared to support the idea
to me that language informs
the not just the way that we package the
world
whether we label it that's kind of
obvious but the way that we see
the world so how did jules's work show
this well
he took a series of color slides like
muscle colored slides
if you're familiar with these well
precise uh
blocks of color and on one
piece of paper for argument's sake there
were different shades of yellow
and another one there fragments say
there were different shades of green all
equally
the difference between one side of the
next with the same colour differences
but uniformly so they went from like a
dark green if you like to a light green
or whatever the
uniform color difference between each
one of the slides
and um on the sort of okay yellowy one
uh if you showed that to europeans
said which is the odd one out if you
looked
really carefully not always but
often you'd say the one at the two
o'clock position but it took you a lot
of time and you literally actually in
your mind's eye
compare all the slides with each other
and if you were lucky you said yeah it
was that one but i i've done this test
and sometimes i don't even see it myself
it doesn't jump out
it's not obvious it doesn't pop out and
some of the times i make that decision
wrongly now you show that to the hinder
and they sort of smile
it's the two o'clock one immediately no
it called me places it leaps out of them
and then we get the the green ones now
on the green ones there's a blues
tile so they show that europeans what's
the odd one that the blue one
show that to the himber and that guy's
got a stick and he's
rubbing his head and remembered his
imaginary beard and i can't work it out
now when you look at that from a western
linguistic fact
how can the person not see the blue one
is the odd one out well it turns
transpired nimble got very restricted or
very limited
color vocabulary compared to europeans
and
no doubt he took someone from the himba
threw them into london for after a
period of time there
they would perceive the blue pop out you
meet just as quickly as we do it's
nothing to do with the hindus
colour system it's an effect brought on
by language but
to me what makes this really powerful
is it's a pop-out effect right the
hyundai immediately get the one that's
the color boundary that's important to
them pops out to them because they've
got a name for it and it's a
i can't remember what it was whatever
it's an important thing and it pops out
at them straight away
for us the blue green color boundary's
important and that pops out to us
straight away and that because it's a
pop-out effect that says that it's
to me it's actually what it is like to
see
the slide the himba cannot possibly be
seeing
green and blue in the way that i am
otherwise the blue
jimmy would pop out of them because they
must be seeing something
bloody weird but not they aren't seeing
those green and blue tiles like i am
in their mind's eye for once a better
word um and similarly when we look at
this of oprah yellow ones they must be
seeing that quite differently for me
because i can't tell the odd one out
with rb and quickly in the way that they
can now i think this gives this
very strong evidence to me at least this
is the way that
i would like to use george's work and i
must underscore that i don't think
he would be comfortable with any of this
but this is the way that i
like to use it to say that you know that
the language is actually affecting
how we see the world so when i say that
our understanding of the world it's not
just it's not just what's going on in
the brain the brain is instrumental to
how we
see and perceive and interact with the
world but it's not just that it's our
entire body
and also the body in the environment
and also within a social network of
language users
all these things come together to enable
us to form perceptions of what it's like
to see
and what it's like to speak so the idea
that we could just reduce this to mere
neural firings or even worse
just some bloody manipulation of symbols
by a computer
is just ludicrous as far as i'm
concerned i i can see the the logical
thought train here so you're saying
jules said that language informs the way
we see the world
you know one potential problem my
interpretation on
his work that's fine that's fine but i
suppose
where i'm going with this is that it it
does it's starting to get towards this
very kind of
ultra relativist constructivist view of
the world and
i i want to put an anchor the reason why
it's interesting is when you're talking
about um
sensory states that it doesn't actually
seem like such a bad thing because
everything you're saying there
completely makes sense of
of course depending on where you are in
the world and your and your language and
so on
you you might have very very different
sensory states and you might experience
color differently
but but then there's there's like a
topology isn't there so then you start
getting into
um understanding and semantics
right and and then you start getting
into knowledge and truth
and at some point you know people might
start to disagree with you that that we
should have a kind of
um ultra relativist view on what informs
those things
so where do you draw the line there
right well
i've one of the lovely things about
being an academic is that you get to
work with some clever people i'm not
clever but i've been
blessed by working with a number of
people who bloody well are
and um at the moment i've got a a
postgraduate
who's mind-boggling i like to say the
other way around we're going for a
discussion and i come out feeling i've
had my
mind blown away and then he's sitting
there looking quite
shift with how the way the discussion's
gone now his particular thesis
has raised some really interesting
questions and he runs with his very
post-modern ideas
in extremis and i i i'm on one
particular
uh uh seafood vision we were i'm
diabetic and
and and and he was trying to make out or
he could give me this argument where my
my diabetic is just an enactment of a
certain practice and i'd say
that's nonsense i'll die if i don't do
this how can you decide
you know the cell call thing uh the
toefl conspiracy or you know if i if i
leap off a tall building i'm going to
bloody well die it's not a social
concert this
um but anyway um paulo's work is is
very very nuanced and he does make some
radical claims when you make radical
claims you've got to be very very very
careful about how you use the language
so um i'm certainly not going to try and
paraphrase
his thesis in five minutes on here
because it's incredibly nuanced
piece of work but i just want to take
one aspect from it that i think is
interesting because i think it reflects
on the world that we're living in now
and gives us an insight with possible
insight
into how trumpism and the echo chimba
culture has taken root
because paulo and i'm not saying asking
that you go along this i'm just trying
to
report this as best i can from our
discussions
parallel thinks that we don't just
have uh epistemic perspectives
on a universally shared world
we each of us ontologically can have our
own
distinct ontologies and why does that
matter well if
it matters says power though if you
start
looking at how this is reflected on
on twitter if you have a community of
people and one of my other postcards a
guy called christa mario
did a film called right between your
ears which i can't recommend harley
enough looking at an end of the world
documentary full-length documentary
feature on on the end of the world cup
on an end of the wildcat in america and
how these guys were saying that reading
the bible was going to end on a certain
day and of course it didn't
and how they then dealt with that and
then the leaders i was going to
end again in six months time yet again
it didn't and chris's film was just
looking at how people can arrive at
these
real beliefs and i think there's
something akin to that with the q anon
movement
and you have this idea that you know
somehow trump was going to lead and the
result was going to be overturned then
it wasn't well something that is going
to happen i think
if you're not in that how can people
have these bizarre ideas
well how would i if you get in the
community of like-minded people if we go
back
to our basic philosophy and don't buy
into a correspondence theory of truth
so much as a coherence theory of truth
where a proposition is true
because it coheres another with the body
of other propositions that you take to
be true
when you're interacting on a daily basis
with people in your facebook
bubble who all share the same beliefs
that's outside that bubble look bloody
bizarre they're reinforcing this thing
so
your view of the world your ontological
view of the world becomes really real
you're drawn into this and that's why
people get
so aggressive about it because it's not
as an academic might abstractly
discuss the truth or falsity of i don't
know
newton's laws emotion or something this
is what the world is you're questioning
something fundamental
about these people's experience of the
world
we've kind of covered a couple of big
names tonight we've had touring come up
and searle
uh the other big name that's kind of
been floating in the background is
girdle in in terms of like girdle
and chabak the the famous book on human
creativity
and uh you kind of point to the girdelli
and i will skip the other guys but like
the godelian argument against
the possibility of machine intelligence
just for for the guys out there that
kind of want to get a bit of a grounding
on
why his name has been coming up so much
can you kind of just give us a very
brief primer on
um how good alien incomputability
kind of relates to the impossibility of
machine intelligence
and how that kind of ties into the other
arguments we've been hearing tonight
yeah um i think in the arc of paper
which you guys
i think helpfully signposted at the
beginning
uh um a lot of intelligence is stupid
there's a as best as i can give it a a
a one paragraph summary
uh in mathematical form of the girdling
argument and
i don't think it'd be helpful to go
through that line by line
now if your viewers are interested i
refer them
to the detail that's in that paper but
to just sort of talk a slightly more
abstract
uh wider view um
i think yeah i'm sure girdle and
shearing
were both aware of the implications uh
of their work on uh
on logic in girdle's case and on
computability in turin's case
and in fact as there are some people who
think for turing
and possibly for girdle as well some
people have made the claim that this
disconnect between turing's a validly
physicalist to desire to explain all of
human mentality
uh via a computer program plus what he'd
learned professionally about
the existence of non-computable numbers
led to a big tension in children's life
and there's a documentary that's looked
at
dangerous ideas i think it was called
that explored
girdle cheering and cantor in that
context of people who came up with ideas
in their own work that challenged
intuitions they had about the world
but coming off the girdle although i'm i
feel certain that girdle and turing are
both in their mind gone through the
implications of their work
as far as i met one of the first times
where this this was actually
cashed out in terms of an academic paper
was by the oxford philosopher john lucas
in a series of exchanges with another
philosopher called
paul bennett in the 60s
where to cut to the chase i think that
lucas's argument is
much more uh blunderbuss and less
sophisticated than penrose's
version of this so i commend anyone
interested to look at
shadows of the mind rather than go back
to lucas but lucas basically says for
any
any consistent uh mathematical system
there will be sentences in that system
that we
outside of it can see to be true the
girdle sentence of that system
but which we can prove can never be
shown to be true by that system unless
the system is inconsistent
and so that
lucas says you know you give me only any
version of
computation that you like uh i can i as
a human can step outside of that and see
things about that computational system
that it provably cannot know for itself
and that's i think the first place where
this argument sort of
took off um penrose's own
take on this is a little bit more
nuanced he likes to imagine
looking at in the shadows of the mind he
looks at uh
computations of one parameter uh and
looks at the question of whether
he looks at the halting problem
effectively if you're familiar with that
on a function of one variable
and that's can you know is there a set
of rules that will allow us to deter
to tell of any function of one parameter
whether that function is computable or
non-computable
and he shows how that leads to a
contradiction uh and
and if we follow the the lines of the
proof we see that there comes to a point
where we
see the particular statement on the
operation of computation k
given k as input uh we can see something
about that computation
that it cannot possibly terminate that
cannot be shown to be true
following the rules of that system
itself and i think that's an
interesting uh an argument and as i said
i'm not
it seems to me when i've read
commentaries on penrose most people have
criticized his
his speculations on quantum physics
rather than
what he has to say about girdly and
logic in fact
penrose was famously invited to give the
keynote at the
centenary at the vienna conferences
honoring girdle for the centenary so
i think if there was some school by
error because you occasionally goes oh
pep rally is wrong and uh uh
i think that the penalty is not stupid
and i think if there was a school by
arrow in his work i i i'd like to think
you'd probably found it by now but
i can recall when i was at the
university of reading having an
immensely long exchange with someone
about penrose's ideas
i won't name them but they were at the
university of sussex and after this had
gone on for months and months and months
and i was saying look look at this look
at this look at this paper and in the
end the guy
turns back to it said life's too short
to waste it reading what penrose
actually wrote
and i've come across this so often
people think they know what penrose has
said
oh they think they know that soulsweat
and they haven't bothered looking at the
source material on either
and yeah yeah this is an issue that
comes up time and time again and that
that was quite a shock to me though when
this guy did eventually concede that he
hadn't actually read pen nose at that
point i hope he has that but he hasn't
been
fantastic well um professor bishop it's
been an absolute pleasure honestly thank
you so much for for joining us today
and um i hope to get you back on the
show soon
well thank you i really i can't i seem
to be very rambly an
unfocused discussion i tried to think
how you're going to
get something interesting out of all
this but that's your genius behind the
editing
machine i feel
honestly it's absolutely fascinating i
think we don't really have much of an
opportunity to
talk about philosophy of mind and talk
about some of these deeper issues and ai
and i think this is a really fascinating
framework actually to think about
some of the various different focus
points i mean you know we had pedro
domingos on last week talking about this
that was awesome i really enjoyed that
that paper i read the paper that you
foregrounded and also watched the
little video that you did accompanying
it and um
yeah i thought that was a really
interesting uh deeply interesting paper
effectively you know i'm making the case
that any
any grading descent train neural
networks doing nothing more than a look
at
interpolating between its training
points effectively which is a
profound uh statement and uh
i need to let them just settle over that
but that was yeah brilliant
if nothing else i mean yeah reading that
was a great thing for me
with you guys it's good for deflating
some of the deep learning hype too
just to kind of like contextualize but
like also with with regards to the night
you've fleshed out probably 10 people's
reading lists
or people's um reading lists for the
next sort of 10 years
um i i wouldn't worry too much about
rambling all that means
is that there's a lot of ground to cover
and not a lot of time to cover it in
this is the reason why i invited you on
because a lot of these things are very
impenetrable
and when i read your paper it's like a
google maps kind of point by point
stepping stones list of all of the
all of the important things that i need
to know in order to it you know to get
my head around this and i think it's
actually
a really great starting point for people
that are interested in philosophy of
mind and
understanding and consciousness and so
on to to read that paper that you wrote
if i said read one book on the on modern
cognitive science i'd say look at evan
thompson's mind in life
unfortunately it's a bloody fat book but
it it i think it's
that is a genius book but i just there's
two
watching a number of your podcasts now
and i'm really enthralled by all of them